So indeed these big price drops
were caused by stock splits,
why do stocks split?
The most common reason and
as far as I know,
the only reason,
is that the price is too high.
Why is a high price a problem?
Well, consider for a moment that stock
may be above say $500 per share.
People like to buy
stocks in groups of 100.
So that means, for instance,
it would be $50,000 to buy or
sell a block of 100
shares of a $500 stock.
Now, of course,
you can buy it in smaller blocks.
That's fine.
But another aspect is that
options when they're traded on
stocks are usually traded
with regard to 100 shares.
So options covering 100
shares of $500 stocks,
becomes suddenly very expensive and
less liquid.
So from the point of view of options,
and
also individual stock shares,
very high prices are a problem.
Even in the case where you want to
buy just one share of the stock,
let's suppose you're setting
your kid up with an account, and
you want to buy one share of Apple.
Earlier this year that
would have cost you $600.
So even buying one share of a very
expensive stock can be a problem.
Finally, one other issue here is if
you're building a portfolio and you
want to have a finely tuned proportion
of each stock in your portfolio.
If some of the stock
prices are very high,
it becomes difficult to get that
fine resolution that you want.
So, when the prices get very, very high,
what the companies do is they say, look,
let's take that 1 share that's price at
$300 and break it into 4 shares at 75.
So that's called a 4 of a 1 split.
In this case, we had a 2 for 1 split.
So that's why splits happen.
Now let's look at this data.
Suppose you read this data
into your computer and
you were going to analyze it and
look for trading opportunities.
Well, your algorithm might discover,
hey,
look, here's a great
shorting opportunity.
Whenever this condition occurs, whatever
that was, you want to short the stock,
and then you'll see a 75% drop, and
you'll reap a significant reward.
And also here,
you might identify this time as
a good opportunity to short as well.
Well, of course, that's wrong
because what's happening underneath,
is that the value of the company
isn't really decreasing.
You just have more shares.
So if you want to trade using this
actual closed data, you have to
account for all these splits.
And that becomes cumbersome.
So someone came up with a great
solution to this problem.
Mainly, adjusted close.
Or adjusted prices.
And the idea is to create a timeline of
prices that are adjusted to account for
these changes.
Such that you can look
back over adjusted close.
Simulate buying at a particular time.
And seeing how the value
increases over time
accurately without having to account for
these splits.
Here's how it works.
The first thing to point out is that
at the very last day, in other words,
today, adjusted close and
actual close are always the same.
Now we track back in time and
adjusted close and
actual close are exactly the same.
But then, on this day,
when we see this 2 to 1 split.
What we do is we go back over
all the historical data, and
we divide it all by 2.
So the first day before the split,
we get about a $125 price
instead of that 250.
Then when we get to this 4
to 1 split we divide by 2,
and then by 4, so
that on this 1 day before that split
our price is in
the neighborhood of about $70,
and that continues back in time.
As we go back we adjust for
each of the splits in history.
So now we have a nice smooth price
timeline without these big jumps.
And for instance, if you consider that
you bought the stock on this day and
held it until this day, the accumulation
in value that you see there is accurate.
That reflects all those splits and
you would have a lot more shares here,
but this would also correctly
represent the increase in value.